le département et antenne réunion vous
présente lien social
[Musique]
vanille ananas rome ce sont souvent les
ambassadeurs de notre île sur les salons
agricoles
mais la réunion a autrefois cultivées
d'autres produits phares comme le thé ou
le café dans les hauts de saint joseph
johnny et emmanuel tente de réhabiliter
le thé de grand coude
bienvenue au labyrinthe enchanté
[Musique]
san jose a dit papa bon dieu et devrait
descendre si l'afer doivent attendre
devant nos yeux
c'est à grand coude dans les hauts de
saint-joseph qu'un vestige de notre
histoire régionale revient peu à peu à
la vie grands coups de géographiquement
à vol d'oiseau c'est le village habité
le plus proche du volcan et ce village
naîtra avec une première grande culture
qui sera celle car au labyrinthe
enchanté pas question de parler de tes
sans évoquer d'abord l'autre culture
historique du village
on va vous passez l'apple l'aller les
stratégies radio à l'origine c'est donc
le géranium qui était cultivé à grand
coude face à la concurrence
internationale
il a été remplacé par le thé mais
quelques années plus tard cette culture
est abandonnée à son tour on va
commencer pour la langue à ce que vous
connaissez comment ça fonctionne
aujourd'hui johnny tente de ressusciter
les deux cultures
plus question de les mettre en
compétition pour lui elles sont même
complémentaires votre mémoire ben mon
cher à nos jeunes plants et à
l'intérieur de géraniums j'ai planté des
allées de teillé pour faire des brises
banques à problèmes d'érosion
comme ça si on a un cyclone ça nous
permet d'avoir un brise vent est bien
consciente retire le géranium j'en
retire le thé en même temps ensuite tous
les ans quand j'ai taillé l'étayer le
théier va me faire du compost j'ai payé
avec sa roue nouveau mon sol va redonner
une nouvelle génération sur le site
à l'entrée du labyrinthe la brume se
lève
c'est dans ce paysage émis des
mystérieux que le thé se développe le
mieux le thé blanc
le thé vert ou le thé noir
fabien de cette même récolte ça vient de
ce même taille et qui va changer c'est
la transformation s'étayer sont des
rescapés des anciennes plantations en
johnny et sa compagne décide de
reprendre le terrain laissé en friche on
est d'origine de grandclaude on aime nos
villages on a tous mobiles au t on
en temps normal on allait jouer dans les
champs de récolte c'est là qu'on a
décidé de se lancer dans le thé de
valoriser des cd rom acteurs au goût du
jour le thé de la rue
[Musique]
alors vendu l'exploitation fait huit
hectares c'était culture quand même très
vivace à une plantation qui date des
années 50 5 qui est toujours là
aujourd'hui qui est toujours productif
c'est vrai que le coût de main d'oeuvre
est très élevé de dans la récolte
manuelle et minutieuse reste peu
rentable c'est sans doute la raison pour
laquelle ces agriculteurs de grand coude
sont aujourd'hui les seuls producteurs
de thé en france une fierté pour nous
parce que bon c'est vrai qu'on
représente le thé de la réunion et en
plus cela on peut vivre de cette culture
là on est quand même quelques ça
quelques personnes intéressées
exploitations ont fait quand même une
famille c'est l'exploitation aujourd'hui
l'activité économique pour les habitants
curiosités touristiques et historiques
pour les visiteurs aujourd'hui ces
élèves sont en sortie pédagogique
il prépare un exposé sur le t2 grand
coude les informations qu'ils
recherchent ont été disséminés dans le
labyrinthe on va les laisser ensuite
chercher les radios si les conditions le
permettent
malgré la pluie les jeunes se prête au
jeu et à l'arrivée pour les réconforter
rien de mieux qu'une tasse de thé or
quand vous étiez très fort dans le
labyrinthe apparemment là aux
apiculteurs du thé blanc du thé vert
pour que la qualité du thé très
important par contre que toi qui est
très important c'est la qualité de l'eau
pour les gérants c'est aussi l'occasion
de présenter les produits dérivés de
leur production comme les sirops d'été
on peut mettre c'est un média ou de
nature on peut mettre quoi dans les tirs
on peut être usé dans le foot le pro maj
dessus dans le fromage blanc
la diversification c'est le secret des
propriétaires pour rester viable
économiquement
notre but à nous c'était vraiment de
utiliser la plante dans tout son
ensemble et de vraiment travailler ou
faire un maximum de choses avec un vivre
que du thé
c'est pas forcément suffisante
par contre se diversifier à voir plus de
gamme de produits c'est plus intéressant
pour présenter à la clientèle une
clientèle qui pourrait bientôt s'élargir
dans quelques jours le couple s'envolera
pour paris
ils vont participer au salon de
l'agriculture et ont été accompagnés par
le département dans cette aventure
le salon international de l'agriculture
qui se tient à paris est la vitrine du
monde agricole français en cette année
on nous aurons 24 exposants sur le stand
réunion sur les 600 mètres carrés que
nous proposons au lieu de 9 l'année
dernière par exemple et nous venons en
aide puisque nous leur mettons à
disposition le stand l'emplacement et
n'ont rien à payer
on participe également avec les autres
partenaires à aux frais de séjour donc
ce n'est pas rien une opportunité pour
ces agriculteurs et une belle revanche
pour le t2 grand coude n'a envie de
faire découvrir à la métropole tout ce
qu'on a ici que la réunion sage déjà
qu'elle a du thé chez elle quelques
puits sont consommés et puis ensuite va
et que la france sache qu'elle a du thé
français ici sur le terre
[Musique]
le thé était cultivé à grand coude de
1950 à 1960 2
à l'époque il était reconnu comme l'un
des trois meilleurs thés au monde en
2005 le labyrinthe enchanté relance une
petite production de thé et de géranium
cette année le thé de grand coude
s'invite au salon de l'agriculture du 24
février au 4 mars à paris en tout 24
exposants réunionnais participeront à
l'événement ils ont été accompagnés par
le département la région réunion et
libertés pour plus d'informations vous
pouvez vous rendre sur le site du
département au www.cegedim.fr
[Musique]